welcome to philanthropy in action where
we uncover the wonderful stories of
people who give their time talent and
treasure to change the world these are
stories of philanthropy I am Maxum
thorne and I teach philanthropy in
action at Yale University I'm thrilled
to have today Julia valentina and Noah
Beckwith with us thank you so much Julia
and Noah for joining us thank you thank
you we also have our brilliant and
dedicated Yale students participating in
the conversation students please
introduce yourselves hi my name is
Connor Bell I'm from Lynchburg Virginia
I'm a junior majoring in history of
science medicine public health hello my
name is Mario Suarez I'm from Newark
Delaware and I'm studying political
science hi my name is ur be Abraham I'm
from Flushing Michigan and I'm studying
global affairs international development
my name is Claire Davis I'm a sophomore
from San Antonio Texas studying ethics
politics and economics my name is
christina lee i'm a junior from san jose
california and i study history hi I'm
Stephen banks I am a senior computer
science major from before a mission
Julia Valentina is a recognized expert
in impact investing advising family
offices high net worth individuals
governments and banks around the world
on development and implementation of
impact investing programs in addition to
teaching impact investing at the
university of st. gallen in switzerland
she's on the board an investment
committee of CFM the development finance
institution of Switzerland she holds an
MBA and PhD from the University of st.
Petersburg Russia and is a chartered
financial analyst Noah Beckwith behind
began his career at the economist group
covering Africa and the Pacific for the
economist intelligence unit and the
economist newspaper thereafter he spent
12 years creating private equity funds
focused on the small and medium-sized
enterprise sector in Africa Asia and
Latin America with a Commonwealth
Development Corporation and oreos
capital he is now an independent advisor
to multilateral Development Bank's
development finance institutions
foundations and family offices on impact
investment strategies noah holds an MA
and modern languages from Oxford Univ
versity at an MSC in development
economics from the London School of
Economics Julia and Noah I'm so glad
you're here and delighted to have this
conversation about how you impact the
philanthropic space with your knowledge
of impact investing starting with you
Julia it is astonishing that you were a
senior executive of AIG and you adopted
this frame of impact investing how did
you come to do that well I think
realistically looking back it probably
was the birth of my first child I
started investing 18 years ago in 94 I
with abb financing and developing
large-scale energy and infrastructure
projects around the world primarily in
emerging markets and there you kind of
see that each investment has impact with
a positive in terms of saving
environment and energy efficiency
renewable energy or negative we had
issues with three gorges dam in China
which had social negative impacts and
then I moved to AG and I was managing
direct primary kuti portfolio which was
you know a glamorous job but after the
birth of my first child you kind of
think what are you doing it for why are
you spending so much time away from your
child if you don't do something which is
meaningful and I wanted to go into
philanthropy and NGOs but then I thought
that actually combining the commercial
approach with the philanthropic
objectives in one would create a very
impactful strategy and that's how I
started developing the impact investing
fund and energy all right well our class
takes a broad view of philanthropy we
talk about how you use your time your
talent and your treasure to change the
world or Noah you've been of impacting
philanthropy because you advise people
and entities and how they use their time
challenge and treasure how did you
become engaged in this I suppose it was
quite a circuitous route really and by
starting this part of my career at the
Commonwealth Development Corporation
which was the United Kingdom's
development finance institution
there had been a very strong focus on
small and medium-sized enterprise
development and that by the mid 90s had
really sort of intercepted with what we
can now call the accession of the
sustainability debate the sustainability
discussion and came to be labeled impact
investing but the idea already by the
mid 90s was that by boosting and
supporting growth in the SME sector what
if SME it's smaller medium-sized
enterprise sector this was a way of
promoting not just economic development
but also private sector development
economic growth and ultimately
potentially controversial II in some
cases poverty alleviation and it so the
idea for both of you is that the market
offers the solution for alleviating
poverty is that a fair statement I don't
know if I would say that it offers the
solution I would say that it offers a
particular solution which not speaking
for Julia but certainly for myself is
perhaps a more disciplined one in that
it brings commercial rigor to businesses
that are growing in and serving
lower-income groups do you agree with
that I do agree i would just add that
there are certain social challenges that
cannot be necessarily tackled through
businesses social justice is difficult
to find a business model but there are
others where if you find a sustainable
financially sustainable business model
you can scale and increase the impact
tremendously because you're not going to
be dependent on limited amount of
charitable dollars but you can engage
capital and people who require
commercial return to tackle those very
cute social problems and that's the
beauty and excitement about the impact
investing Julia walk us through an
example of saying the case of malaria or
bed nets in which you make a distinction
I believe BTW an impact and outcomes and
and how you would convince an investor
this may be a good place to invest
well the whole discussion about impact
and outcomes stems from the notion that
you need to measure impact to know
whether you're reaching the objectives
if you are an impact object impact
investor by definition you aspire to
achieve both financial returns and
social impact understanding whether you
achieved your financial return is easy
you look at how much money you've
invested how much money you received
either through dividends or by returning
the capital it's easy how do you know
whether you're reaching your impact
goals that's where the measurement of
impact comes into play and typically
what people would measure because it's
easier is the outcomes for example to
cure malaria a commercially minded
social enterprise will sell bed nets
they would measure the success of their
impact objectives by measuring the
number of beds that they have sold but
in reality doesn't necessarily mean that
they are curing malaria which is what
the end goal is because maybe those bed
nets are not used maybe people buy them
and go fishing with them so there's not
necessarily dialing direct link between
the outcome basically what are you doing
and the change that you're trying to
effect with this investment can you
think of an example in which it is
legitimate that you can merge the two
we're we're the the outcome is a good
substitute for the impact I am a
practitioner so I always look at it how
much would it cost and how much of
management time it would take to measure
because measurement of impact should not
substitute the creation of impact so I
would argue that in most of the cases
you should start maybe with simple key
performance indicators even if they mean
focusing on outcomes at the beginning
and then wherever it's possible and
doesn't take too much of management
attention you can go for
further and make more deep analysis yes
it's not perfect but at least it will
encourage people to start evaluating
impact and I find impact evaluation is
important not only in understanding what
your dollars are doing but also in
focusing the attention of managers bait
a social entrepreneur or a fund manager
to pursue those dual objective and not
only focus on financial objectives
because it's the only one which is
measured it's the only one that you are
accountable for I mean if I could come
in there complementing what what Julie
is saying I think that there are there
are several problems in this in this
area one is that there has been such
complexity acquired so quickly in the
number of indicators that are being
measured the difficulty that it actually
takes physically on the ground in
Cambodia or El Salvador wherever it
might be to measure these these
indicators and additionally what's often
forgotten and I think implicit in what
Judy is saying is that there has to be
significant resource and time dedicated
on behalf of the investing company to
capture this data offer leaving aside
the whole self assessment debate in and
and and conundrum which takes time and
getting businesses to work and to grow
in these markets as often challenging
and opposite ears to burden them further
by asking for all sorts of qualitative
and quantitative data remember these are
companies that in some cases might not
even have basic financial systems is an
additional burden so we have to question
ourselves as the practitioners how much
pressure we're putting on these
businesses I'm so glad you said that so
let's get this question out of the way
use you still believe that there is a
role for traditional philanthropy that
impact investing the business model of
working through the market is not the
way that we're going to change the world
exclusively we don't believe so no it's
all that no it's not that I don't
believe that but i think that n i think
that what what impact is investing is
saying is that there is a mobile i don't
know if i would say that works there is
a model that we are trying and that we
are developing as a community that
essentially says with investment dollars
and the commercial rigor that hopefully
accompanies those dollars one can access
issues of affordability quality access
choice availability of key goods and
services for lower-income groups in a
way that is perhaps more sustainable
because the long-term viability and
durability of the company in question is
safeguarded because it grows with that
capital and and hopefully lasts whereas
there's always this question or when
does the philanthropy run out either
because of fatigue or not on the on the
part of the giver or because that model
is no longer possible or sustainable for
whatever reason I mean is it life
support Julia would you make that
distinction for us between what Noah
said goods and services mm-hmm which
seem to be a compelling space for impact
investing and and and other spaces like
social justice I would actually not
necessarily agree well no I think that
there is space for traditional
ground-based philanthropy but the focus
should be more on catalytic philanthropy
and accountability in reaching you know
really creating of change rather than
you know spending in a writing checks
for example you know if you want to
support children who are orphans you
know very difficult to create a business
enterprise so charitable dollars will go
to reach this goal an important
dimension of charitable dollars is also
at the start of impact investing with
when a cattle eating new model is being
tested it may not provide the returns so
there is a time in the development of
social enterprise where they can only
survive on charitable dollars an example
would be barefoot power which provides
Solar kids for the remote villages in
Africa they sell them at $12 which
represents three months of you know
kerosene sales and they last five years
so after three months the household
starts to save money they have 12 12
times the luminosity they can start
micro telephone charging businesses huge
financial and huge social benefits but
they had to start with philanthropy
because at the beginning they didn't
have the distribution systems their
product was too expensive it wasn't
commercially viable now they entered the
space where they can scale and attract
semi commercial capital and then
hopefully they will go further by
continuing research and development
expanding creating economies of scale
and they can attract purely commercial
so I think they're they're still you
know a you know a space and place for
philanthropy so let's bring in our
students Connor it sounds like there's
great work being done through this
framework I just wanted to connect the
conversation to someone that we had last
week who's Harry Belafonte very famous
civil rights activists in the US one of
the things that he mentioned was that
traditionally he kind of conceptualized
philanthropy as the rich giving back to
the poor as a means to kind of offset
some of the social injustice a--'s that
they have caused prior to that working
in private enterprise and you know
especially launching this investment arm
with AIG is that a criticism that that
you face often and how do you how do you
respond to that can you define what do
you mean by the criticism of what I'm
not sure the criticism of private
enterprise capitalism in particular kind
of leading philanthropic initiatives to
combat social injustice which some
people argue is in part manufacture
by the class system created by
capitalism itself well I would yeah i
would also answer may be in several
point you know first I think yes there
is a lot of uncomfort among the
philanthropists with the notion of you
know receiving a return on the provision
of social goods so that's one point
second point the vehicle that I created
with energy was commercial you know it
was focused on double bottom line you
know impact investing but we were hoping
through private equity to achieve you
know good financial returns and we did
have a criticism saying that it was
impact washing that the financial
institution just wanted to use it for
the PR but i think that at that point
you know you know it wasn't true it was
just a bunch of people who worked hard
because they believed in it and it was
in a way very gay stick from my side
because i felt very inspired with this
idea so for me it was fantastic to work
on it and push for it irrespective of
what the organization was doing in the
room in other parts and the fact that
this commercial organization which many
said is not really prone to support it
has provided 150 million dollars out of
their balance sheet to support this
initiative and was ready to increase it
three times to do it i think is great so
if we can move large commercial
institutions to play in this field still
getting the financial returns because
without it you cannot do it then i think
the impact would be tremendous important
is that it becomes their core business
that is not the corporate social
responsibility on the side driven out of
the marketing department but they find
ways to create new products for bottom
of the pyramid to drive their
profitability and business lies and then
it becomes impactful i think they're to
complement what what what judy has just
said i think the reality is that there
is a spectrum of motivations some of
which we all might be more comfortable
with and some some some
which less so from the purely cynical
window dressing green washing marketing
all the way through to very enlightened
understanding of the fact that there is
an enormous market out there that by and
large is larger in number than our
traditional Western consumptive markets
and therefore it's simply a commercial
opportunity bringing it back to the sort
of personal speaking for myself I
noticed attention at aureus capital for
example where I felt that I was perhaps
you know more of a believer in that side
of the mission then my colleagues on the
ground that were you know cutting the
deals as it were but then I made peace
with it in the following way which was
if at the end of the day between us we
are getting the dollars to move into
these SMEs and to grow these SMEs the
fact that I might be more focused on
generating as great social environmental
and governance impacts as possible and
they might be more focused on on the
financial engineering of the transaction
perhaps the ultimate return wasn't the
some greater than its parts and didn't
we get to a positive result that's
promoting equity through social and
public goods for all as opposed to in a
sense sitting in judgment that other
motivations were perhaps as pure is
opening mind do you think this
particular form of philanthropy it's
have you seen it be compatible
compatible with with other forms maybe
not as you know large coming from you
know large private enterprise is there a
lot of partnership there do you even
think of it as that's great no i don't i
don't think of it as a philanthropy but
i think that you know a lot of
philanthropists in a lot of people who
come from that side who are driven by
impact are more and more attracted to
this form of achieving the social impact
i look at it and we've discussed it a
bit you know during lunch is that
you can be a purist and you say i want
my dollar to alleviate you know poverty
directly and you can say look i want 90
cents of impact per dollar of my
investments and i'm willing to give ten
dollars to this course or you can say
let's find an opportunity where I will
get good financial return and I will
achieve 20 30 cents per dollar of impact
but because I receive the returned I'm
willing to put 10,000 of those dollars
you calculate your impact would be much
higher because i think this notion of
financial sustainability liberates huge
amounts of capital in addition to
liberating also the interpreter will
drive of finding the solutions where you
accountable for the products if you give
a product as a grant say this is the
same solar lamp you don't care how good
it is if you sell it even for a fraction
of the cost that you will sell it in the
West you are accountable to your
customers they have to buy it they have
to like it they have to come they can
come back to you and say this is really
it doesn't work you make it better make
it cheaper make it last longer and what
is important you treat people as
consumers you treat investees as
partners not as the nation thing so it's
much more empowering but I think I think
also it might be helpful to look at it
from the perspective of philanthropists
that that get into what we could now
call the impact investment space and
I'll give you the example of a of a
family office in California that I used
to work with quite a lot when I was a
tourist capital and they invested in a
number of our phones 80 people full-time
working on this family's well from very
significant family office and the
particular family member that did
ultimately invest in a Latin America
farther than Africa fond had a very
nuanced view of what she was doing and
why she was doing it so she had her
philanthropy books and she was very
clear about what that might achieve too
many of Julia's points well
was interesting about the way that she
approached this impact investing volks
and this is private equity farm going
into small and medium-sized enterprises
was there is an economic development
story happening in Africa where we are
and Latin America where we are
empowering small businesses with capital
that they can't get from formal
financial institutions I am
participating in both an economic
development story in a wealth building
story because these companies were
hopefully grow and take on more workers
and I am also doing good in that broader
amorphous sense so she perceived it in
its own right as something related to
but but but different to philanthropy
merius I just wanted to ask about what
the role of risk and failure is within
the realm of impact investing you had
mentioned that certain projects or
things which don't have a proven track
record that is that's the realm of
philanthropy dollars and that's the
realm of of grant grant making when what
is the point where it becomes viable for
impact investing where is there is there
for me as an investor I think you know
there are different type of investors
there are angelyn masters who may be
willing to put even you know risk
capital to prove the pilot but in many
cases if it's the idea itself has not
been you know tested then you know it
might be difficult so typically in
impact investment space because the
concepts I knew and they might be less
profitable because there is a social
dimension and social orientation it
might take longer for companies to be
profitable and they might not be exit
able at the same valuations so many
impact investments are maybe not as
lucrative in terms of financial return
or could be riskier every startup you
know they have been stats produced about
how many startups die you can say that
you know logically you may have more
social enterprise startups that would
die because it's more difficult to
perceive
objective and balance those objectives
but what I've heard and we've discussed
just you know a couple of days is that
social entrepreneurs who are driven by
mission tend to stick longer with the
company not exit as early as may be
commercial entrepreneurs who would say
no it doesn't work I have to fold and go
do my next thing they wonder they're
really driven by mission so they're
willing to try and try and try so fail I
can have a different dimension it
doesn't necessarily mean it doesn't work
one model doesn't work you recreate
yourself you change the model you try
another thing so one of the mantras of
private equity investors is management
management management and first business
plan never works so I think this is even
probably so much true it for their
social impact investments your i would i
would actually possibly reframe the
question or at least and another
important actor which is or series of
actors which is the development finance
community i think that if development
finance institutions really are being
true to the D in d fi they're called DF
eyes then they are there to also play
that catalytic role for mortals both
business and funds so aggregated models
that work as a means of channeling
capital to these emerging businesses and
so you'll hear phrases like first loss
and guarantees where they are signing
themselves up in some cases to lose a
hundred percent of capital in the hopes
that that some of these businesses that
otherwise wouldn't attract capital so
correcting a market failure will attract
will will be invested in and so it's not
just if you will up to philanthropists
and there's a very vibrant debate going
on at the moment within the development
finance community about quite how
developmental they should be the
argument purists say should be an if but
for argument were not for them this
would not happen so that's a whole other
range of actors I would just suggest it
we should have in the mix they're
complicated complex financial structures
being built which includes the different
layers of capital
from development finance institutions
from philanthropies maybe taking you
know the first laws you know to
accommodate different risk and return
appetites of investors to make sure that
even earlier stage and tested projects
can get the necessary financing and
there's discipline that that's required
on the part of the development finance
institutions the International Finance
Corporation which is the private sector
arm of the World Bank Group in the 1990s
became very very good at saying as much
as we would like to invest in the second
and third and fourth iteration of this
fond bearings vostok as an example which
is a very successful fund in Russia
which they seeded it is time for us to
bow out we've done our job this is now a
billion dollar fond attracting purely
commercial capital so as Julia said I
mean you've got foundations investing
alongside dfi is investing alongside
commercialize development finance
institutions as I just said well as I
can be disciplined Julia flew in from
Zurich to join us and has to catch a
plane so Julia thank you for joining us
we're going to take a short break so
that Julian didn't get on on her fact
deserve and will continue our
conversation with Noah Julian thank you
so much thank you very much Maxim thank
you very much fantastic questions it has
been fun great hi um so my question is
it pertain to Julia and the social
business when you put a for-profit model
to a non-profit model you're essentially
combining two different notions and in
one with the selfs benefit aspect of
capitalism and the self-sacrifice notion
of nonprofit so how do you think that
impact investing and children businesses
balance that having to develop their
selves with having to promote social
good what you mean both a statement on
capitalism this self self service it's
more of self approximate yeah
approximately maximizing but i would i
would challenge that within the context
of impact investing which is that if you
if you are at all interested in i
believe seek a prior lads argument and
you
you see this as a sort of symbiosis if
you will there's an opportunity to
combine both the servicing of an
unattended market with social goods that
otherwise that said market would not
have access to that they needn't
necessarily be mutually exclusive I mean
I think of setting it up could you give
examples when you say unattended market
what does that mean exactly it's some
specific language that means I mean
let's take let's take access to finance
for example people who are excluded from
access to financial services on with
these people being these would be
generally very poor people often in in
rural but also semi urban or peri-urban
areas who are discriminated against or
excluded on the base of physical
location on the base of literacy on the
base of inadequate physical records on
the basis of lack of land holdings
ten-year assets collateral on the basis
of gender and so by so for example
peasants in Peru or what a mother Oracle
Guatemala hours for for example sit down
outside of outside of Phnom Penh in
Cambodia and you have a vertiginous
drop-off in rate of access to finance
because there are physically no branches
there and depending on how that
oscillates with mobile telephony you
either will or may or may not be hooked
up to a financial institution take take
some of some of the investments that
I've made in the past but we've invested
in in in financial institutions that are
aiming to provide additional services to
the poor both in volume and type so not
just access to basic loans but also
perhaps micro health insurance
micro-insurance more generally crop
disaster insurance I believe that there
you have to go back to your language
perhaps that capital it capitalist
impulse the investors in the form that
made that investment are looking for a
return but we're also achieving enormous
social vertically not and potentially
environmental good when we get into
agricultural financed by extending
financial services to these previously
excluded groups so I think if I make
the way that you set up the question is
quite is quite provocative which is
great but I would I would I would
challenge some of the I here sort of
marks underneath remember screaming from
his grave follow-ups chin so we read
small change where the author criticized
small businesses and their work in
countries where inequalities exist and
you said that you're providing services
to these people who would otherwise not
have them what the author of small
change would say is that businesses
ignore the fact or the roots of the
cause of inequality and would rather
just use inequality to their service by
providing their goods and by almost
creating a monopoly would you say that
this is correct that businesses can't
affect much past providing services that
they can't create the social movement
and the civil society that's needed to
remove the inequality completely I
actually think that that's a very myopic
view of of small businesses and their
origins and and how they develop I'll
give you an example at the moment I'm
working with the Gates Foundation on a
medical clinic fund that they're going
to invest in undoing the due diligence
for them so I'm looking at on their
behalf and the viability of small
businesses small primary health care
providers that is the only source in
almost all cases for lower income groups
of any health care if they can afford it
in the first place so I don't I don't
get how someone can say give you the
what what you've just asserted on their
behalf I mean are you know they're not
exploiting inequality they are doing
what little is being done to try to
attend an enormously overlooked
unattended discriminated marginalized
group so i think it's i actually think
statements like that are quite
irresponsible i think also you would
have seen all sorts of changes and
perhaps even unrest if you think about
the fact that in many of the countries
that we're talking about the SME sector
the smaller medium-sized enterprise
sector accounts for sometimes up to
ninety percent of economic output it
just stands to that makes a bit of a
nonsense I think I think
you are avoiding a question right what I
hear implicit in or its question is it
is we accepting what you said that you
have expanded business services even in
health care hmm it could be in a system
that's incredibly exploitative yes which
there's massive inequality where women
are treated as a in a very suboptimal
way that it's not addressing that it is
simply addressing providing and
expanding necessary services but not
addressing fundamental inequalities in
that particular society do you disagree
with them no I don't disagree and I
think that's a fair point i mean i think
that one also has to be realistic about
how many issues a single business can
take all you know so for example back to
the financial services example we had
before when investing are we going to
work with that institution to look at
discrimination by gender and literacy
and physical you know there's a limit to
what each institution to do but no I
think that is that's a fair statement
clear okay another one of the books that
we read for class was poor economics
co-written by Professor Banerjee from
MIT and one of the things that use
discusses is micro lending and how the
international development community has
changed their respective of micro
lending in the past ten years ten years
ago it was sort of seen as the Silver
Bullet for international development and
today we're seeing more problems with it
and not really seeing it as much of a
tool for poverty alleviation perhaps
consumption transformation but not
necessarily poverty alleviation and I
wonder what do you think about this
change is micro lending still going to
be the future of impact investing impact
investment or is it on the way out what
many many as she's packed in there let
me take your loss statement first and I
think that it is fair to say that
microfinance generally let's use it as a
generic term was one of the first areas
or sub sectors if you will that caught
the attention of the
both commercial investment community and
also perhaps the philanthropic community
foundations alongside multilaterals as
this silver bullet as you as you put it
so we're impact investing is concerned
it's it sort of been there and been
around the block i would i would point
to to sort of seminal moments within
that one was was what muhammad yunus did
and the other was a very big transaction
where ABN amro bank of holland bought
bank or l in brazil specifically to get
access to their micro finance portfolio
so that was huge it was the first move
by commercial bank that was saying to
the market this can be highly profitable
i think that you need to unpack what
microfinance is or has become and i
think again underlying that criticism
one has to draw a very important
distinction between explicitly consumer
finance orientated institutions that are
providing small loans small amounts of
capital or credit and others that are
doing very different types of
microfinance or in some cases both
there's payroll based lending there's
group lending there are very there are
many many models and one can debate the
the impact that any given model has but
i think that one has to look at those
you separately from from from financial
institutions that are providing you
alone for example to buy a television or
to buy a white good and that is a debate
that we could have as to whether or not
that's that's you know a good thing or a
bad thing but it is different so I'm
nervous about lumping at all in one but
do you agree mmm that there were ten
years ago there was a sense that micro
lending will result in such widespread
business development that poverty would
be alleviated and the new one says that
you just said which is quality of life
may improve marginally people can own a
television people can do various things
doesn't reach to the level of what we
would have considered alleviating
poverty
level so what I hear you say is it is
still a benefit and there are
significant benefits but that's a
different question to whether it's
alleviated poverty yeah I think in some
instances it can alleviate poverty so I
believe that more microcredit in fact
where an individual who is able to grow
a business to a certain level that then
has impacts of the following nature her
ability to educate her children say a
female her ability to spend more on
health care and so on there is no
question that that can help to alleviate
poverty I think one of the reasons why
it hasn't perhaps become the silver
bullet is less to do with microfinance
and more to do with the fact that the
continuum of financing in financial
services depending on or oscillating
with the company as it grows that is
available to us in our markets is not
available to these very very small
emerging businesses so if you imagine a
kiosk that then gets there first access
to a micro credit loan who's going to
take them next the reality is that the
traditional financial services are not
winning yet to reach down and give that
person their first $25,000 I think
that's where we've seen a ceiling hit
and so the scalability and potentially
broader poverty deviating impacts then
then hitta seating as well and just as a
follow-up to that a lot of this research
was based on individual case studies in
particular areas and I wonder how much
do those sorts of case studies
contribute to your opinions your advice
about where impact investing should go I
mean I think that if you if you suddenly
broaden out the lens to impact investing
you're going from microfinance and
you're taking in right or just just
generally how do you use case studies
which probably are are pretty
centralized in a particular region to
inform your advice or do you or do you
at all do you think it's appropriate to
use a case study out of Bangladesh and
apply it to Latin America no absolutely
not i mean i think i think one of the
key
the issues here and and one of the
lessons that has emerged is that the
cultural specificity with in Bangladesh
let alone taking that model and applying
it to Bolivia or wherever it might be is
extremely dangerous and limited and that
brings us on to another issue which i
always find fascinating which is this
current fascination and obsession with
the word scalability what does not
actually really mean because there's
there's this worrying dynamic at the
moment in the impact investment space
that unless it's scalable it somehow
isn't legitimate but not every solution
can be scalable and are we also then
sort of denigrating and undermining very
small local achievements and solutions
that we're creating so I would bring
that into the discussion as well Thank
You Kristina yes thank you so much for
coming to speak to us today we have read
a lot of different views in our class
about the role and the ability of the
free market to address problems of
social inequality and help these
marginalized populations that you've
been speaking about we've read views
about this idea of philanthropy ilysm
where there's this idea that people who
have made it in business have a hyper
agency and they have they're able to
give in a way and invest with a lot of
impact and then on the left side we have
read you know criticisms of corporate
social responsibility saying that
companies that are for-profit inherently
cannot cannot address these issues of
social inequality because they're
responsible to the Board of Governors to
their shareholders to investors so how
would you address that critique and
where do you think impact your idea of
impact investing falls in this spectrum
I think the reality is I think that I
think the key word that you just use
this spectrum right I think the reality
is it is a very broad spectrum and there
will be some businesses where a more
distinct and perhaps difficult choice
has to be made between the impact of the
profit motives and some not let me give
an example to your to the second half of
your of your question I'm on the board
of a company called clean engines
incorporated that company is looking to
retrofit tuk-tuks I don't know if you
all know what took took sabado the three
wheelers that that you find in in many
many Asian cities there are an estimated
one or two hundred million around around
Asia one took took is responsible for
the equivalent of 50 cars worth of
emissions toxicity in Asian cities like
Manila and Bangkok is actually starting
to kill what this company is doing is
retrofitting took talks with clean
engines using LPG or compressed natural
gas the moment that vehicle has been
retrofitted not only does the drivers
income double but the efficiency goes
through the roof the toxicity over time
obviously falls in in the in the in the
city because they're these totals are no
longer pumping out the emissions right
there is absolutely no reason and I
don't think from my perspective any of
us should have a problem with the fact
that this hopefully one day will be a
multi-billion dollar company we could
also significantly significantly impact
pollution rates and health amongst the
poorest of the poor urban dwellers
tuk-tuk drivers in a range of countries
that to me is is it is a pure impact
investment win-win where you've got a
sort of uber profit motive if you will
and a lot of money eventually being made
with an extraordinary private sector
resolution to a problem which certainly
the public sector and the government
hasn't touched or being able to do
anything about but having said that not
every business has such a perfect
symbiosis if you will between the social
Annie and the and the profit side or the
financial side so your point is also
well taken that's what makes it so
complicated how do you in your relative
of advising advising people who have
serious wealth significant wealth and
you can help them with your analysis and
guide them to purely philanthropic ends
or you could advise them to invest in
the took took clean energy example so
you can actually say in a bed net
I say we can save babies immediately by
having medicated vêtements distributed
or you can actually use your funds in
this way how do you make how do you as
an advisor make such a call and do you
ever find yourself trying to steer them
in one direction or the other or you
leave it up to them I I don't find
myself trying to steer them in one
direction or the other unless clearly
I'm representing a particular product
where I'm where I'm trying to fundraise
that's a very different scenario but i
think that the hopefully the biggest
impact that we can have is clarity and
helping them to articulate their own
agenda and priorities and in some cases
although this can sound room was
condescending there is a blurring in
their own minds of the of the
distinction between impact investing
like the took took example and and and
the bed net example and even within bed
nets one could intersect in that in in
in a more commercial way and in a purely
philanthropic way so i think what we're
trying to do is we're trying to help
them articulate a set of priorities in
their in their activities that that that
goes through the gamut of opportunities
by geography by sector by type of
transaction are they interested in debt
or equity are they interested in gender
issues are they interested in infectious
disease but i think that in to answer
your question in my advisory work one is
generally dealing with people back to
the example we used earlier that have
already in their minds drawn a
distinction between what we might call
you know cure giving and something where
they want to participate in an economic
development story as they see it and
therefore can also get excited sometimes
about seeing that money regenerated into
almost like a mini revolving fund within
their wealth of it they can then put
back to back to use in another
opportunity i want to address the
blurring problem because one of the
concerns that comes out of the
literature is that for people who blur
impact investing with pure philanthropy
it is shifting pure philanthropy into
that space
and as Julia said in the earlier part of
this two-part conversation we still need
to maintain a level of philanthropy that
isn't getting a financial return are you
helping people to make it very clear
what the choices are and the different
endpoints of both of those I think we
would be responsible if we weren't
because I think what's implicit in your
question and what what is dangerous is
that and as Julia was alluding to there
are many socially orientated businesses
that were it not for philanthropic
capital simply would not get to the
stage where even the most early stage
risk hungry impact investment vehicle
would take the blindest bit of notice of
them so I think there's an onus is on us
as the community to emphasize the
importance of both aspects but again I
think it goes back to helping to educate
them on the return both financial and
non-financial dimensions that they can
expect from both buckets if you will
Stephen thank you for talking with us so
it sounds like we're characterizing the
role of philanthropy to be this
catalytic investor that then makes
impact investing feasible once it has
one say an idea has been shown to be
productive but and then impact investing
is interested in addressing these ideas
these generally goods and services ideas
that are able to produce a profit and
produce social impact but what about
those areas philanthropy like malaria
for example where there is no possible
way of creating a social impact
investment I guess what I mean is so
there are these companies that are
producing bed nets and there are people
who need them they're able to purchase
them and that is earning money and
creating social good and that's great
there are many many more people who
either because of lack of education or
because of simple lack of funds are in
dire need of these nets but are not
purchasing them how
it's not a case where it is appropriate
for philanthropists to invest in a goods
and service type project in order to
address the sheer lack of a business
model to address the problem I mean I
couldn't agree with you more I think
that I think that there are cases like
the one that you you raised where what
has come to be known as the impact
investing model be at private equity or
debt or whatever simply is not going to
apply I mean there are and perhaps isn't
something that we don't really want to
look at in the face but I believe that
there are certain social goods and
public goods that perhaps the market and
private enterprise in this sense is
never going to be able to address in the
way that you you know that we might hope
so I don't think it's appropriate for
all sectors and problems I actually
agree with you but Stevens Point poses a
paradox if in fact they are businesses
that are reaping profits by engaging in
the production and distribution of bed
nets wouldn't philanthropic engagement
with an undercut those businesses how
can you convince a consumer I can get
this for free why should I pay you as a
business social venture business or
whatever for the same thing I can get
for free but look in who the consumers
in most of these goods before they get
to the end user they're the World Health
Organization's of this world and so on
so i think is that you know this is a
little bit more complicated in that but
you know got me fair point and fair
paradox um oh come on the concert I have
the opposite of that one it's yeah
Steven to to your point i would say that
there are many regions of the world that
have just not yet been reached by those
organizations that are handing out free
bed nets and if i'm a person living in
that organization then and i see that
i'm not getting a free bed net it only
makes sense to purchase one and while
the facts remain is there i don't think
that philanthropic efforts to get free
bed nets and some people are
undercutting the possibility for impact
where people just are not yet getting
those bad nuts no but I mean your butt
but your previous statements sort of
implies that the person in question has
sufficient disposable income that they
can make a choice
that they will they will buy all they
won't buy well there's not a free one so
i'm going to buy i'll buy one sure i
mean i think it varies from person to
person it sounded like Professor Thorne
was suggesting that there are such
people who would then choose not to
because they could later get a free one
mmm that right yes isn't that I mean
there are examples of that ya know and
that's a problem but I mean I think it's
the engagement of sort of NGOs and
philanthropy and so on in that manner is
is deeply problematic because for two
reasons one the displacing the
displacement effect what you're talking
about the two and this is rivoli a side
of it is the motivations and it's all
another debate well no it's much just
talk about that a little bit fast an
insider when you say the motivations
what do you mean well let me give an
example of sort of disruption that gets
ugly one investment that that i was
looking at when i was at aureus capital
as part of a health care forum was a the
first indigenous syringe manufacturing
company in East Africa in Kenya now you
have something very strange going on in
East in East Africa something very
strange is happening where you have
demand for approximately 800 million
syringes in the whole of East Africa and
if you imagine what's going on there
particularly the moment and you have
supply of about 400 million and they're
being imported mostly from Asia they're
being imported at about two dollars a
syringe and they're being sold in some
cases all the way up to sixteen dollars
a syringe someone somewhere is making a
lot of money and I think we can all
guess who you know these are these are
people in government and so on and so
forth but the ugly side of it is that
the international institutions sometimes
the the NGOs and other actors even
philanthropic actors foundations are
helping to perpetuate this market and
failure and market distortion and and
being Frank with everyone in the room I
think one of the unfortunate everyone in
the public's expense I think one of the
one of the unfortunate conclusions that
we came to is that particularly in the
case of some of these more sensitive
sectors like health care and often less
if you like impactful ones
often telecoms is a good example in some
cases financial services and I wonder
having had this experience the extent to
which some of these sectoral II
orientated funds how far they can go
because when you start to tread on those
entrants public sector interests you
suddenly find that the company that you
were going to invest in didn't get the
import permits that it was looking for
or isn't able to import the plastic
resin that then makes the syringes
that's going to undercut that whole
market so it becomes very very much
disruption as murky and and just to
fashion that because they are players
who are making a profit perhaps
internally so they for people who are
pocketing that spread between the two
dollar import prize and the 16 dollar
sale price they have an interest in
keeping the market exactly as it is
absolutely no Julia Noah thank you so
much for coming here today we've been
inspired by your intellect by your
passion for impact investing and by your
enthusiasm to help change impact
investing around the world these are the
stories of philanthropy that are so
important to us and thank you Yale
students for have made this conversation
so rich and textured thank you for
joining us this has been philanthropy in
action at Yale University now please
what are you going to do to change the
world